le village de réseau donne le départ du
circo à vélo pendant dix jours sur son
deux-roues assistance électrique la
députée aurore bergé va parcourir 240 km
à travers cinquante et une commune de la
10e circonscription des yvelines
le but mettre en valeur le patrimoine et
les acteurs locaux du monde culturel
l'idée c'est aussi de redécouvrir ce qui
existe à côté de chez nous tout le
patrimoine de proximité tous les
artistes qui existe parce que parfois ce
qui est juste à côté
c'est un peu ce qu'on ignore parce qu'on
va le chercher plus loin de l'évasion
alors qu'en fait on a toutes les
ressources ici donc c'était aussi les
mettre en valeur tout simplement
première étape de ce tour à quelques
mètres du départ l'ancienne maison de
robert doisneau
l'occasion pour le maire de faire
connaître l'histoire commune entre le
célèbre photographe du 20e siècle et son
village doisneau représente pour les
habitants et nouveau moi mes anciens
habitants quelque chose de familial
s'est ouvert et les habitants de la
commune connaissait la famille doisneau
les enfants de vanneaux puis ses deux
filles donc à tout un passé qui essaient
de maintenir quelques minutes de pause
et c'est reparti fin du tour prévue dans
dix jours à montfort l'amaury le 7
juillet prochain